bonjour fabrice prochasson
nous sommes dans la bibliothèque de
l'école lenôtre alors vous êtes chez
nous depuis longtemps on va en parler de
directeurs des licences et une
assistance technique et puis et puis une
actualité toute récente janvier 2013
vous étiez le coach de l'équipe de
france est de tibou ruggieri qui a
reporté voilà mais à côté de nous le
bocuse d'or de l'or tout à fait
magnifique récompense
comment dire coach de l'équipe de france
ça c'est un peu par surprise
automatiquement parce que bon nous on
avait décidé de préparer qui m'aurait
jury avec monsieur rich riley dans le
but de se qualifier et de gagner
l'épreuve france commence comme ça en
fait la période là faut dire que le beau
gosse de recettes internationales
nationales pays au café 92 à vue est en
fait une fois qu'on a gagné sa sélection
nationale on l'a droit participer à une
sélection continentale à partir de là le
candidat à un coach qui le suit qui est
devant on fait pire pendant les cinq
heures trente années de compétition et
donc j'étais nommé donc par les équipes
de bocuse d'or noir canalisations
général et monsieur paul bocuse et
l'organisation qui nous voilà ça fait
qu'il a demandé de représenter on va
dire le chef français il devient le
coach officiel du candidat français bon
c'est pas c'est assez rare que ca le
chef d'une même maison qui
comprend la valeur fois stephen jay
gould inquiéter le candidat français
s'était dit prêt de la maison lameloise
qui était il reste le site officiel donc
là c'était quelques pas des choses bien
faites et bien pensé tu vois je passais
pas fait exprès mais de pouvoir
travailler avec thibault dans la même
maison automatiquement m'a aidé
énormément pour se préparer parce que je
le connais très bien pratiquement ses
proches aujourd'hui est bien vite le
métier très vite et puis c'est clair que
cette rentabilité bon d'être
le coach qui s'est cassé trois côtes
dans ce genre de concours rien cause
dans ce concours c'est beaucoup de
responsabilités et c'est pour commencer
je pense protéger un peu le candidat au
no 7 et thibault
l'idée c'est travailler ensemble sur
toute la partie à veut dire j'avais du
concours donc à la fois sur le côté
design conceptuel le côté recettes après
déjà tout ce qui est médias basques
automatiquement une des demandes de
partir le véhicule à un peu là pour
garder l'attention
pas déjà et puis après tout les
partenariats donc c'est vraiment très
très large et en gros c'est une sorte de
nounou qui est la vague gravier sur le
candidat la fois psychologiques explique
éric temps giresse et apprendre à
gouverner tout seul un gros paquebot
auquel ford l'avait revient donc en fait
on est là on a des voyants tous les
côtés au départ c'est qu'il est beaucoup
beaucoup de rouge beaucoup d'orange n'y
a pas beaucoup de verre et puis à la fin
en fait le coach vaudois a laissé
pratiquement l'avion tout vert se sauver
ces petits bouts qui reprend l'avion
tout seul équivalent posée le 30 janvier
il a gagné c'est un peu ça c'est
vraiment le rôle du coach serait préparé
un candidat veut dire à pouvoir se
positionner à faire ses recettes
numériquement et surtout travaillé sur
le conceptuel du lotus d'or est déplacé
stressant c'est beaucoup de
responsabilités parce que derrière c'est
la profession donc c'est 900 mille
personnes ils ont utilisé la france et
la france parce que vous l'avez pas eu
depuis un moment que cela on n'avait pas
depuis 2007 donc c'est clair que là il y
avait une attente énorme sur une très
grosse pression de tous les chefs chez
paul bocuse le premier qui avait passé
un message rapidement en disant qu une
victoire de la france que lui faire
plaisir déjà qu'on reçoit là comme
message wyss apporte son lot la
fellation base il fait important la sens
là je voulais voir quelqu'un on sait
gagner un salon qui suivent
automatiquement puis maison de notre
maison mais il avait dans sa sélection
d'hôtels automatiquement la
responsabilité est forte il a préconisé
stressant vous êtes vous êtes meilleur
ouvrier de france a jusqu'au stand 96 96
6 fm
vous était presque plus stressés là
qu'on s'était pas vous directement vous
étiez coach que quand c'était vous qui
passez pas le même stress devrait
automatiquement ce que l'idée en
préparation psychologique justement de
concours c'est surtout préparer thibault
c'est d'apprendre à éviter le stress
dakar voilà donc ça c'est alors c'est
pas évident votre expérience en
expériences de tous les grands
événements chez lenôtre est votre
approche est fait pour vous concours
automatiquement sait comment aborder ces
compétitions est la plus importante au
monde pratiquement donc on a vu un
paquet de grands sportifs un dernier jeu
de long mais surtout à pékin dont le
chinois qui est loupé sa corsa
est malheureusement souvent de talent ou
le bas et dans la préparation sera de
coaching là deux solutions soit on joue
un peu place et je dirais dont on peut
jouer le podium j'ai entendu c'est plus
simple et plus facile je pense qu'on
aurait pu jeu comme çà ou là on aller
d'un bout - difficulté ou au décès des
lieux où on dit avec le trio en tapant
dans la main après maintes réflexions en
quatre semaines qu'on a fait le sujet
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est y aller pour
faire quelque chose pour monter sur le
podium où chercher la victoire il faut
qu'on s'engage et et qu'on a signé
d'accord ou saas la victoire on souffre
ensemble voilà donc ce qu'on a fait
c'est clair que nous on n'est pas parti
comme des sauvages entre guillemets sur
les films ferland dès jeudi travailler
faire des centaines de filet de boeuf
garniture les frais parce qu'on voulait
derrière nous on a travaillé sur le côté
vraiment conceptuel on sait plaire avec
avec des micros et vous n'osez pas aidé
c'est un baiser vous des images à la
sublime donc c'est clair qu'on a choisi
rapidement le thème de versailles parce
qu'on est vraiment présenté à l'arrivée
il fallait que ça représente la france
c'est la conscience qu'ils soient c'est
facilement identifiable ils sont la
france
quand le plat sorte de la cuisine des
mois que sont optiquement c'est que les
jurys qui vont voir passer le pl10 c'est
vraiment la france
vous parlez des deux jeux olympiques de
sport wins d'abord vous êtes vous un
sportif oui vous avez la complète de la
compétition tout à fait inutile
athlétisme beaucoup péché compétition
entame de compétition vous en faites
encore sachant pas encore jetés champion
du noir et à 3 ans et plus alors vous
avez beaucoup de travail et pour le
nôtre pour des gros événements sportifs
des jeux olympiques de tamouls alors
j'ai une très grande expérience
justement sur les grands événements
sportifs on me dira monde entier j'ai eu
la chance on va dire à travailler par la
maison de notre patois noir donc mon
premier grand événement c'était
l'organisation des coupes du monde de
football en france on va aux 90 à
traduire ses chefs de cuisine est à quai
sur la cour en gérer les dix stades j'ai
dû faire ça comme de match je crois sur
les 65 c'est 18 mois 24 - avants 13 sur
papier complètement on écrit le
fonctionnement vont travailler comment
on va produire comment qui ont à choisir
pour nous aider après si les briefer les
bonnes équipes automatiquement sur les
castings
après c'est y croire alors
automatiquement que vous allez arriver à
matin la finale coupe du monde on a 22
milles couverts et 15000 après le match
vous voyez si on n'y croit pas déjà si
difficile déjà faut être un entre
guillemets un leader mais sans écraser
les gens c'est le leader qui va faire
que les gens vont suivre parce qu'ils y
croient ils ont envie de vous faire
plaisir mais surtout que les gros
clients ça séduit des questions de notre
ans était toujours le client le client
le club on a fait ça les autres les
petits c'est exactement ça c'était
c'est gaston mono moi je suis parti
comme il disait en essais fiscale
d'automatiquement moi c'était un
monsieur qui m'a sorti la production
chez le notaire très jeune 24 ans qui
m'a passé cadre 24 il ya un tas
d'histoires ce qui fait que nous on est
très motivé pour travailler ses
conséquences et votre famille quoi
c63 famille et c'est clairement ce que
l'on trouve plein de choses beaucoup de
valeur c'est une très belle maison
aujourd'hui qu'elle rejetait pas le
groupe sodexo mais c'est vrai que tout
ça fait qu'on est très rond du filiale
on va dire complètement gérer à la
maison un autre travail notre envie de
transmettre moi je suis mis à rêver de
france mon grand père a aussi été mariée
à la vôtre groupe de bois céleri voici
le radar tout à fait de rideau c'est le
travail du bois en fait un de la sortie
de tonnes de riz bon encore où il
apprenait en fait à travailler le bois
le torsadé et faire des tonneaux avec de
fond un rond et ovale avec un cercle
milieu pour séparer les termes à monaco
terme abrogé rocla il a gagné 155 et
c'est clair que bon c'est moi j'ai
toujours et non par les propos de lutte
oui
vraiment en parler beaucoup mon grand
père et en plus c'était président des
mof du haut rhin serait donc tous les
dimanches j'avais toujours eu la bêtise
15 personnes revenaient et est
responsable aussi sur la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des lourds et
donc pas ce que vous devez pas oublier
travaux
créateur voilà c'est ça ouais c'est non
moi j'étais pas du tout là dedans je
n'étais pas intellectuel non plus
j'étais un gamin qui travaillent et
moyennement
qui apprenaient bien mais sans
travailler entre guillemets j'avais
moyenne très très classique 13014 bon
c'est vos parents il faut un métier quoi
c'est ma maman maman la vie tuera pas
faire d'études et ira travailler faute
avait
peut-être non puis c'était mon lycée cd
oui mais paris
dans la campagne dans le loiret ce qui
est important c'est d'avoir un métier
travailler est patent voilà bon les
études n'étaient pas encore complètement
acquis c'est un peu différent
certainement et d'autres ma mère a
téléphoné à blois m'a inscrite et je
suis dépassé les examens des eurobonds
je sais pas trop quoi en vendée comme
histoire pour que toute manière c'était
pas du tout ce que je voulais faire et
j'ai pris quand même et puis du coup je
fais à saper de cuisine un bep de
cuisine un bac
c'était assez vite remarqué rapidement
way très rapidement moi j'étais pris
dans de belles maisons je suis
maintenant en 88 aussi
rapidement après l'armée s'alarmer en
fait je me suis fait repérer par gaston
et ses chefs et je suis rentré chez
lenôtre et je veux dire très rapidement
je suis passé de d'ouvriers à se mêler 4
après quatre rounds je voulais déjà que
vous passiez le
première fois je suis pas vrai c'était
ouais j'ai refusé les seconds se mouvoir
matin en 92 pour m'inscrire pour 93 en
me disant tu t'inscris tue parce qu'il
m'a fait je suis un peu rebelle entre
guillemets et moi c'était clair que je
le passerai pas ce que tu façon j'avais
décidé j'avais première mongolie après
quoi j'étais prêt c'est votre côté
compétiteur ouais t'as fallait gagner
quoi oui c'est pas mon style entre
guillemets de passer les concours pour
s'amuser donc j'avais refusé sur la
d'inscrire
j'étais prêt techniquement bon
techniquement et psychologiquement voilà
donc du coup je m'étais entraîné sur
cetet mof 93 comme commis un des
candidats donc j'avais déjà répété un
petit peu la face on se prépare à 96 et
je me suis inscrit le dernier jour 31
295 pour passer 96 1 pouces et est à 2
minutes tracé passait pas et j'ai pas ce
que vous aviez dit nordausques aussi
comme ça mais la pression c'est ça
permet de se motiver se rassembler après
la tête automatiquement et après bon ben
j'ai eu la chance de gagner l'épreuve de
films de finale à blois déjà donc ça
c'est ça qu'on très difficile parce
qu'en fait
ils étaient 700 83 candidats 48 au final
et après la finale il faut avoir 16 ans
donc c'est assez énorme mais c'est vrai
d'abord la première fois c'est assez
rare donc j'étais assez fier de cela dit
c'est une maison et gagner encore
combien de
dizaines
d'autres c'est une maison formatrice et
voilà vous avez évidemment des souvenirs
absolument rien on parlera pas l'effet
de la coupe du monde de rugby et les joj
tout le gober aux ouvriers de france et
la banquise de la pression vous êtes
toujours dans l'avenir non un plus que
dans le passé
passez moi j'oublie je fais pas
attention parce que je fais toujours un
peu d'un spray section des idées j'ai
pas mal de rêve dont je encore oui ouais
je pense parce que de manière où on est
avant tout des artistes et
moi je me vois plus comme un artiste
comme comme un cuisinier toit sont donc
et après bon il est pas mal de choses
que qu'on aime à faire qu'on ne peut pas
faire ce qu'on a qu'une vie et des choix
à faire donc après dans la carrière c
jamais évidents ont pu tout arrêter et
faire le pt actuellement c'est difficile
mais c'est possible pour moi ça me
paraît pas impossible en tout cas et il
parle de choses que j'aimerais faire
plier les livres alors il vous avez
publié quelques temps c'est loiret et
gourmandise
voilà et puis vous allez continuer voilà
la suite on va continuer donc là c'est
ma guise je continue sur la sologne qui
juste accroché aurait automatiquement
deuxième partie dans le noir y est parti
dans la 41 et le blésois ouhlala 80
recettes encore à nouveau oui il ya de
quoi faire je vais m'associer lola ya
plein de produits à flins va du vin sur
le mans des frigos cousue pommes de
terre et on va s'amuser merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup et très bientôt